26 year old pro bowler
with the buffalo bills who was four
years old when tom brady made his nfl
debut
josh allen
was i that hole
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right josh allen to play first
after mahomes tee shot found the fairway
little kick right for me
all right we're putting
we put
josh allen going with the putter there
really good
oh this one's good
yeah the international sign of good
drive and he immediately reached down
and picked up that t that's a beauty
tough location in the back left
well maybe not where'd it go but then go
good
i don't think he's going to hit yourself
on the hip after you hit the ball so it
can't be a good follow-through
this is great
oh this is nice going with the little
chip
okay they'll have that for three not
wasting any time here
nailed it love it walking it enough
there are threes
[Music]
oh my goodness we can kill somebody
yeah it's the same spot as they're in
about spectators should have been given
hard hats and helmets when they came in
listen these football players should
have bought a bunch of helmets out here
for these fans they gonna kill somebody
out here
oh
nice shot
[Music]
on tv today
josh what are you thinking here what's
the strategy behind the mulligan at this
point in the game
don't hit anybody
on this one
oh trevor you have been just on point
with the commentary he's
been cutting it they're doing what you
tell him he's been cutting it
so advantage the young guns here
at the par five and josh isn't loving
that
the fallback walk away not a good sign
all right
taking the fifth tee out again
nice shot josh
oh that's a really good shot
pretty good be the right man
that's all we needed josh i've arrived
[Music]
too much power
that would have been too much wouldn't
it
another chance at birdie here for
mahomes and allen
get down
get down
oh
more fish
oh my goodness those must be bill's fans
yeah look at that
a little deep but dry
all right here we
go gave it a good hit up there oh this
is probably good
come on alan
wow
we were so close to seeing this guy in a
waterfall charles started unbuttoning
his shirt that's close enough yeah
that's close enough
close enough josh that was some putt man
what a pot josh that was a heck of a
putt
you